reconciling austerity with
competitiveness and growth that's one of
the challenges of the parliaments budget
committee today mep has approved a
mandate for negotiations on the 2016
budget with a european commission and EU
council two red lines for the report's
author are the reimbursement of the 25
billion euros worth of late payments to
member states and investment in jobs say
in acceptable no papi sake I te echo de
Luna poppy Lee fact you the new Papa
Ledet cinco keeps on the credibility to
confuse will see the croissants mep is
expect a lot of this 2016 budget
investment in jobs for young people and
in smes greater solidarity between the
Member States and beyond the US borders
however there are dissenting voices this
mep believes that d you could do more
with less money amazon fema him game so
I named BJ does octal I still missed
indaba recently off in flash telling
Augustine's in half east Dawa have
pushed him Dee I he'd suffered on CF
Phyllis was da you ferret conductors
units and I starting a fire at Verdun
the next step will be a vote in the July
plenary